this beats represents how much time you
will have in life depending on what part
of the world you were born in the
starting size of your pizza can vary if
you're born in America or somewhere
comparable the average size of your
pizza will be 12 inches with 8 slices
each slice representing one decade for a
total of 80 years of life expectancy
when you are born you get this whole
pizza as you move forward through life
each bite in each slice you take
signifies the decisions you'll make and
the things you'll do with each moment of
time if you're an average American this
is what you will do with it you will go
to kindergarten elementary school high
school and then College in total you end
up spending around three years of your
life towards school or just under half
of a slice if starting around college
you begin a typical career and work
around 40 hours a week until you retire
at the average age of 63 you will end up
spending about 10 years of your life
working or one full slice you also have
to get yourself to where you work and go
to school and any other locations for
that matter regardless of how you do it
on average you'll spend more than three
years of your life in some form of a
commute or travel just under another
half a slice you now have just over six
slices left but you haven't slept yet if
on average you sleep the recommended
eight hours per night you'll spend 27
years of your life asleep more than two
and a half more slices you now have just
three and a half slices left the
majority of your pizza is now gone
all this talk about pizza has probably
gotten you pretty hungry because you
also haven't eaten anything yet during
each day of your life you'll spend
around 80 minutes eating drinking and
preparing food by the end of it this
will accrue to around four and a half
years another half a slice of course
eating and drinking means you'll have to
go to the bathroom on average you'll
spend about two hundred and seventy
seven days going to the bathroom across
your lifetime about two-thirds of a year
if you also factor in other general
bathroom activities like showering
grooming and any other body maintenance
that'll take at least another year
bringing your total time spent in the
bathroom to about two years you will
also spend time maintaining your
physical spaces whether it's your house
apartment car work area etc you'll need
to do things in order to keep your
spaces at least somewhat clean
functional and sustainable cleaning
organizing shopping and general chores
will amount to around three years across
your life
time in combination with the time spent
on self-care you'll spend a total of
about five years doing maintenance
oriented tasks equaling another half a
slice on top of caring for yourself
you'll spend an average of about two
years assisting or caring for others
friends parents grandparents siblings
sons daughters pets and whoever else
might need you that's about a quarter
slice you now have two and a quarter
slices left if you're lucky or just over
20 years of remaining free time assuming
you have good health in your retirement
years and there are any other extraneous
things that you are involved with or
responsible for throughout your life now
what will you do at this time if you are
like most people because of all the time
spent learning work and cleaning
maintaining and helping you'll be pretty
exhausted and you want to entertain and
distract yourself on average you'll
spend at least five hours a day between
your phone or computer and about two
hours a day watching TV both of which
are on the low end of the American
average even at this low average you'll
end up spending a minimum of about 23
years of your life consuming some form
of media content in your free time
that's the rest of your pizza and then
some you're actually a little bit short
you won't even have enough time to watch
all the stuff you want at this point you
might feel pretty dismal you might feel
like life is insanely short and that
you're going away supposed to be doing a
bunch of trivial things but you'd be
foolish to think about it this way this
time is only wasted if you waste it
there are a lot of things a part of life
that you might not choose if it were up
to you to create the conditions of the
game but you can't you can't choose to
not have to sleep or to not have to eat
or to not need an education or a job or
travel time and so on however within
these things you have a choice if you
choose to try and make the most of
school enjoying the time with friends
and trying to find excitement and Wonder
in the moments of learning something new
that portion of a slice will not be
wasted if you choose to pursue work that
you are passionate about a career that
makes you feel engaged and fulfilled
that slice will not be wasted if you
choose to look out and appreciate the
world and it's stunning details on your
commute to work or perhaps listen to a
podcast or an audiobook and appreciate
the time to yourself that portion of a
slice will not be wasted if you choose
to sleep next to someone you love each
night those two and a half slices will
be wasted if you choose to eat delicious
healthy food and enjoy the art of
preparing it as well as sharing it with
people you enjoy being around that half
a slice will not be wasted if you choose
to feel grateful that others need you
that you have the capacity to help
others that you care about and can
experience that level of human
connection that quarter of a slice will
not be wasted if you choose to watch
things on TV or do things on your phone
and computer that are meaningful and
interesting to you things that might not
only entertain or distract you but
enrich you better you connect with you
those slices will also not be wasted and
if any of this is not the case you might
spend part of a slice working to correct
it and ensure that you don't waste any
more you might do your best to reduce
your phone usage or watch less TV or
reduce the duration of your commute or
try and cut down on work hours if at all
possible or in the case when you can't
do any of this you might realize that
even when things aren't perfect or how
you always want them to be at least you
still have a pizza
[Music]
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder